come on buddy
there you go hello friends
hi what's up welcome
i'm currently um in the very
uninteresting process
of doing my invoices so i thought that i
would stream
and talk to you guys at the same time
because you know
it is what it is obviously i'm not going
to show you my invoices that seems like
that would be a bad idea
but i'm doing my invoices um so what's
up everyone i hope that you're having a
good uh what is it sunday night
this is invoice
20.
invoice chip invoice 20.
beautiful
what am i doing up this time of the
morning well it's
uh what time is it 9 57 p.m and i
actually still have quite
quite a bit that i need to do today so
it's
not a lot of work um which just
sometimes happens
you know don't really get uh
time off in my industry i don't feel
like
no i am not dressed up to do invoicing
but i am dressed up
that said i love it that people say why
are you so dressed up
um whenever i'm literally wearing
anything other than a t-shirt
this is not like an unusual thing for
any other woman to wear
um now i am filming something
also tonight that i have to get done so
i was wearing things um
that i'm not allowed to announce yet
that i'm super excited about
but i just have to film here that would
usually be shot in a studio
but alas cove it
so it's not happening
hey yeah yeah yeah yeah um i've never
done one of these streams before i don't
know how people do them
you just chat did i get that right you
just talk right
that's the whole point uh
i'm not allowed to talk about my new job
yet um
when do we hear about the new job from
chill factor and
yellow jello asked the same question
this is what my chat looks like for
everyone who's wondered by the way
people are always like does she read
twitch or youtube more my chat looks
exactly the way it does here so
it doesn't matter to me what platform
you say anything on when i stream on
multiple platforms they just show up
for the record that's how it looks how
it looks for you guys is how it looks
for me
um except that it's coming in more
smoothly for me whereas you guys are
just like
running in um no i can tell you what
what my new job is in like two three
weeks
not positive yet 100 i'm certainly not
going back to ign
not doing that um
but yeah i uh i will be able to tell you
guys i don't know the exact date yet
like we're not positive
but they are certainly excited
for me to announce it as am i um
i would tell you the date if i was
positive of the date but alas
i am not am i a librarian i
wish dude i'd be sick
it cropped up with this shoulder pads
it was good good crop top yeah i
actually bought like three new
oh did my chat just break i think it did
um
let me refresh that there you go buddy
hopefully that fixes it
it's still broken on here though well
how am i gonna fix that
it's working where i can see it but it's
broken on the other side
let me get rid of it and pull it back i
suppose
is this gonna fix it you just fix it did
i fix it no sir
let me try again
[Music]
and i don't know how about how about now
how about now huh
gotta get rid of it entirely brilliant
obs is stupid
that's my hot take terrible
this free thing that i use for
everything all the time
is dumb and bad and it should feel bad
that
should fix it hopefully we'll see how
long that lasts i guess
you can pull that back you do log that
in there we go
sorry about that everyone
what's obs that is uh open broadcast
software which is what
most people use for streaming
so is the new job in the gaming industry
yes of course
it would be a long time before i leave
games we're almost at nine years
in may i will have been in games for
nine years
crazy [ __ ] yeah i'm not leaving video
games
i'm not gonna tell you guys if i'm
moving or not uh if i can
avoid ever telling people where i live
ever again it seems like a great idea
i'm not going to do that uh can i tell
you when the xbox embargo lifts i
believe i can because other people have
wednesday
does it pay well it pays fine
not particularly
um
i clicked the wrong mouse pull my
calendar
why do you always go to april it's not
april dude
what are we doing it's gonna be my
october invoices it's gonna be my
october invoices
october first done
thank you badandi i appreciate that
gonna review games on the channel still
great question official grahams i
haven't done that
in like three years so no there will be
no game reviews on my youtube channel
probably ever again in my life i haven't
done that
in quite some time i don't know why
people think i still do
i guess this is a talk about games a lot
but game reviews and discussions of
games are very different things
obviously
so um the answer is
well i'm not going to tell you what my
invoices are for i mean i can tell you
rooster teeth i guess but like i'm not
going to like
detail my invoices that seems like a
security risk
we should probably not do that thank you
tono
i have not oh well yes no i have heard
of it but i've not seen it
am i still hanging with bruce and
lawrence all the time i last saw
lawrence like
um a couple of days ago
um we did a distanced hang
i feel like you guys already know
everything about the character i play in
cyberpunk
i don't know there's anything else that
i can tell you about that
you've seen it i don't know her name
i genuinely don't know what her name is
it might just be alana pierce i actually
have no idea
so all i've told you is all i can tell
you
how often do i hang with a fun house
crew outside of work i mean virtually
never because of covid
um but i don't think that i will ever
stop hanging out with those people
like i imagine when covert's done we'll
we'll continue to
go get drinks and all that good stuff is
the music too low
should i make it a little bit louder can
you guys hear it
maybe like there we have some nice lo-fi
beats
seems good
oh you guys didn't know that was music
brilliant that answers that question
how about now can you all hear it did i
fix it
it must have been way too low
you can hear it now this is too much
chat happening is there a yes yes okay
it was so low you guys couldn't hear it
but because i've got this little volume
slider on
here i guess still hear it super well my
bad
that was music the whole time oops
uh thankfully i am only playing uh
royalty free chill hop
so we will not have to deal with the
copyright strike even though that's
never really a problem on youtube it's
only ever a problem on twitch where that
[ __ ] gets like
like i've been shadow banned my twitch
chat will know
um where i've been shadow band a bunch
of times it's brutal
i have a play slash reviewed dollhouse
you know what i think i did review
dollhouse
so here's the reality of being alana
pierce
i have played more games than very vast
majority of people right
um nobody believes it because woman or
whatever
but like i've played [ __ ] everything
to the extent that sometimes i forget
what i've played
um and i can tell you if i like hear a
synopsis of it
but the truth is like it's a lot of
games
and i think dollhouse game if that's the
horror game that came out on ps4
i think i did play it
and i thought that it had some cool
ideas but was
overall no yeah i have i did play it
there you go i did um
cool ideas but overall just ended up
being like really repetitive and it
wasn't super annoying
was what my take ended up being
um have i played cyberpunk recently
no i would love to play it again
uh i feel like people are gonna ask this
question over and over and over again
but trevor i'm not allowed to say what
i'm doing yet
uh in my leaving video
i said i will tell you guys what i can
do as soon as i'm allowed to
which is still the case i wouldn't do it
here on this live stream
there will be a video and a tweet and
all that good stuff
um as soon as i'm allowed this isn't a
withholding the thing situation i
promise people always think that there's
like some kind of tactic
um thank you escobar i think that was
what that said
it went too fast it's gone i don't know
where it went um
yeah i don't do it on purpose i'm just
not allowed to say yet
so i'm not saying you'll see
is it really big feels really big to me
have i played valhalla i have actually
when is covered gonna end i i think that
in the us we're gonna be locked down
until 2022 at this point
it's a real [ __ ] it's a real [ __ ] i
have a red
mistborn or star stormlight archive i've
read miss born i love that series i've
actually
not read stormlight archive i know i
should uh when am i going to tell you
i've already answered that a bunch of
times
should be two or three weeks but i don't
know exactly yet
what time do i usually go to bed ugh
i try to go to bed at about 11 or 12 but
it lately has been like there's some
days where it's been like 5am
um all over the place lately
uh thank you john
but no
why green screens oh because they have
uninteresting backgrounds generally
that's pretty much it i to know about
your first next-gen game besides
cyberpunk
um i'm forgetting the release dates of
everything i'm looking forward to the
medium and i'm looking forward to miles
morales those are the two that i like
the closest that i'm
very much looking forward to
excuse me excuse me
i am playing bug snacks soon
did i manage to make a start on the dune
novel i did but i've not read very much
thank you hector i appreciate that this
the chat is moving very quickly i'm just
going to tell people not to donate
it's a bit much for me to see what you
guys are saying like thank you
thunderbird i appreciate it but bye
oh thank you blue eyed beth i appreciate
that
i read the whole thing thank you yeah
i've been very productive
actually in lockdown gotten a lot of
[ __ ] done
um but i'm also pretty sick of it
as is everyone that's the reality
of the world um but boy hell does it get
[ __ ] annoying knowing that like i'm
alone in an apartment
doing my best you know frankly like just
trying to do good things as much as i
can for that move myself accidentally
as much as i can for the world um while
people are just going to halloween
parties
what if you stayed home and we locked
down what if we got rid of it so that
everyone can be back to normal rather
than just you individually
that'd be pretty sick you selfish sons
of [ __ ] but
you know it doesn't weaken my resolve
i'm sticking to staying home and not
seeing my friends ever at any point at
all um except at lawrence who i have
seen twice
because we can make that work with the
setup situation but otherwise pretty
much nobody
um so it is annoying
is what it is come back to australia i
would if i could which i think i
actually probably will be able to for a
little bit next year but
the issue is actually getting back from
australia not going there
um my family is doing well and i would
love to go visit them
but getting back to the us where you
know i'm paying rent and all my stuff is
and my entire life is and i'm
just would be really hard so uh i might
not be able to get back in and i think
the election that is you know happening
this week
should influence whether i can do that
or not it'll be easier for me to come
back
if biden isn't then if trump is in in
theory
uh but we'll see it'll also help me with
my green card
um because trump declined my business
uh proposal um i tried to sign up for a
business
and uh the trump administration is
basically just like not allowing that
kind of stuff right now
so certainly some of my future in this
country
uh depends on the upcoming election for
sure
so i guess we'll see but yeah if if
biden is elected i think i can probably
more comfortably go home
with trump it's a little bit harder as
is the reality of the world
now this is november [ __ ] we go back to
october
uh brian i kind of stopped doing the dj
streams
because i was trying to do them to be
uplifting like my plan was i'll be
positive
and do something that like helps people
relax just hang out and have a good time
and then the chats just ended up being
after like the third one
full of console wars garbage or like
people calling me ugly so i was like
well this doesn't really feel that
positive now because then it was just
making people argue
uh which was like against the point
um so i stopped doing them because i was
like well if i'm trying to be positive
and they've been overrun i don't feel
like there's anything i could do about
that but they're not positive now
because people in
chat aren't even being positive anymore
so i stopped doing it
it's like i can't can't quite make that
happen
console wars are [ __ ] stupid we've
also gotten to
uh a point on the internet where um
people think that the word biased means
something that it doesn't mean
and it's just all over the place and i'm
like god the games community's [ __ ]
stupid sometimes
they think that bias equals like
something but you can like something
and not be biased um it's
you're allowed to like genuinely just my
point is liking something does not mean
bias
and that's what the internet thinks it
means and it's really [ __ ] stupid
because it makes talking about any
section of games positively impossible
and i guess because i
am often positive and also critical of
every single
game company um there are different
people who attack me on a daily basis
for being too biased
like what you're saying is that i like a
lot of things
also the thing that i find the most fun
is i will have one person attack me for
like an hour about being an xbox shill
and then literally 10 minutes later
someone will attack me with the exact
same amount of passion and conviction
for being a sony shell
and what i've started doing is just
sending them screenshots of what the
other person said
because i'm like you both are positive
you're right so sure and i feel like the
split of it that i get is like 50 50.
it's like genuinely like it's just so
wild to read or people be like you want
100 a [ __ ] playstation fanboy it's
disgusting i can't believe you're on an
xbox podcast
or the other split is you're such a xbox
fan boy you're on an xbox podcast
like you're so sure you know and you're
both doing it and
man so yeah i just sent them screenshots
of what the last person said about the
opposite side and they're like well
they're wrong
are they are you all just really dumb
do i just like both because i've always
been that way you know since the
beginning of time
will you still be playing with the fun
house guys i very much intend to
um depends on my schedule obviously i'm
trying not to over promise
but i very very much hope so i have no
plans of of stopping and
and like you know new job is most
important is the reality it means that
funhouse would have to work with me
outside of work hours which is
uh on their choice but i think that they
want to um
so i hope to yeah that'd be real nice
but we will see
i don't i just don't want to promise and
then have it not be a thing
so yeah
that's the thing um
do you agree the media fuels the console
laws from time to time to generate
clicks
is the earning model broke i think
youtubers do that
i've not seen the media do that but i
don't want to speak to it because
frankly i don't [ __ ] pay that much
attention to the media anymore
um i have a lot of friends who work in
games media and i can't imagine that
they are doing that by any means it's
just that there is someone sharing their
opinion that they believe in
that's pretty much always the way that
goes
and of course there are people on
different sides who work at these
companies um but i'm not gonna speak to
it because like i don't i just don't
really pay attention i just talk to my
friends for the most part
i feel like i get most of my game news
direct from from twitter which is
probably why
um media is a lot more competitive now
it's harder
this one's going to be from the first
got it
oh my god that was 9 30
to 1 30 straight oh my gosh
actually 8 30 okay 0 1
10 20.
yes that's correct 8 30 a.m
2 1 30 p.m
[Music]
beautiful
any tips for getting in the industry if
you don't have the resources to relocate
i didn't i started in a city that
doesn't really have much games industry
and my answer would be um
do you just do it you don't you don't
have an excuse uh
brisbane doesn't have games industry i
had to go to sydney all the time um
which you know was
like riding me of any savings because i
just like basically invested in my
future so aggressively
[Music]
i should split these up into two in it
yeah
that's going to be to 10 30. um
but there are so many options online now
that i think it would be easier even
from when i did it um and
10 30.
beautiful
okay this is on the other one
would i ever collab with a startup
company what are my terms
i don't know what's the startup
what are their terms i can't answer that
question
i have no idea that's very vague sir
what kind i'm not against collaborating
with
uh anything but um
i don't think i can be quite that
specific for you fam
this one's gonna be zero two ten
twenty
odds on cyberpunk getting delayed again
in december man who [ __ ] knows at
this point
did i vote not a citizen
can't so no cannot vote i've had people
like attack me for not voting and i'm
like hello
good day mate australian
[Laughter]
don't have much of a [ __ ] choice
there mate no [ __ ] [ __ ] i can do
about
that
i think you're very pretty nikolai 1909
i haven't watched the mandalorian new
episode yet i was gonna do that tonight
but then my day got all [ __ ]
um i was thinking about when i do watch
it
putting together a little mini podcast
thing
maybe with like rahul and jacob and
anthony carboni
just for fun maybe but the problem that
i have
is that i need to stop turning things
into work all the time so then maybe i
shouldn't
i don't know the problem is that in my
head i'm like but that would be really
fun
but on the flip side of that but what if
we didn't
make everything work all the time alana
have you thought about that you [ __ ]
dummy
i'm not good at it though so that's my
thought process there i don't know i'll
talk to the
the boys about it i feel like we'd have
a really fun time doing it i just um
it's an alana problem that i need to
work through you know
this one is 2 p.m to 6
30.
p.m to 6 30
6 30 p.m beautiful
see bible studies 420 nice
i vehemently disagree with the if you
love it it's not work
that is [ __ ] uh and that is an
unhealthy
mindset that these sons of [ __ ] try
to get us into
um you can love something and still get
burned out
and still be overworked and still be
tired no matter how much you love it
so sure my job every day
forever really has been super fun and
i've been doing stuff that i've really
enjoyed and i've always enjoyed my work
um you know being around video games
however
i still need a [ __ ] day off i worked
six weeks straight at ign with not
one day off literally not one day um and
i feel like i've done that the whole
lockdown pretty much and most often i'm
working from 8am to midnight
literally every day doesn't matter how
much i love it
still work you uh
yeah i feel like it's uh exploitative
company people who made that
that call this one is done
general hours
beautiful and this one is going to be
this week's a bit [ __ ] that's a tough
one
it's just an ethical problem we have
with this particular week
uh michael baumann said thank you first
up
do you see yourself being heavily
involved in video game related
journalism miscellaneous content in the
next five to ten years or do you hope to
branch off doing a different career
venture ty for your content
thank you uh i have no idea um truth is
that i'm a very ambitious person
and i will go in whatever direction i
think is exciting um
i can't see myself leaving video games
like i feel like i will always work in
video games in some capacity because
that's where like my
my two passions in life have always been
writing in video games so i feel like
i won't however i don't want to say that
because
the reality of the way that i operate as
a human is
as soon as i feel like i'm not learning
or growing somewhere i think i'm selling
myself short
and and um if that happened to me in
games somehow then that would happen to
me in games somehow
so i won't rule it out and i answer is i
don't know but i have absolutely no
intention of ever leaving video games
um i've been doing it i think i said
earlier in the stream nine years in may
and i'm certainly not bored so i don't
want to leave
um okay
this is actually quite complicated i
don't know this
this part of this invoice is gonna be a
real [ __ ]
okay okay we'll figure it out
uh i did already answer that question
sketch lab oh i realized i've been doing
these invoices the australian way too
the day before the the month i'm sorry
uh thank you amy what camera do i use
for my streams it's a logitech brio
uh colin said is the american accent
difficult for me it sounds hilariously
accurate not at all but i think all
australians can kind of do an american
accent
um it's never been hard for me i don't
know why
zero nine ten
twenty
this one's 9 30 to 10 30.
beautiful
am i at microsoft now i work nowhere now
what's this playlist it is called
royalty free chill hop
hang on let me put it in the chat
nope i was about to do it on my macbook
where i'm doing my invoices
different keyboard bro
there you go there you go
my favorite lightsaber color i like a
purple just because it's my favorite
color in general
what do i do to unwind other than games
i read a lot
i write a lot and exercise
those are the only things that i really
do
do i budget good question scott i don't
budget
because i'm very good at saving i've
been my whole life
so that's not so much of a problem for
me
um i've never really needed to
and i uh i thank my mom for that one i'm
even i'm pretty [ __ ] stingy
here's the truth there are things i
splurge on like statues but even then
i'm
i'm generally just pretty strict with
saving
because i want to buy a house man and i
think a house is cooler than
a 200 dress or whatever the [ __ ]
that is 12 30 to 1 30.
oh yeah yay how do i deal with negative
situations
i don't really feel like i get into a
lot of negative situations if i'm
completely honest
my life's pretty drama free
so i ever play games with my fans um i
have done
apex legend streams before
and um i was thinking of doing or
continuing to do those so
yeah uh if you add me on xbox it's the
easiest way for me to do it while also
maintaining my own safety um
because that's really the only public
account that i actually have for the
record every other account
that i ever stream from is not the
account that i actually use you gotta be
careful about that [ __ ]
um
so yeah uh add me on xbox it's
charlanazard and then i will like post
when i'm doing those and i invite people
through messages
um brandon booker said how do you manage
your time as someone who is consistently
on youtube
i don't feel like i am consistently on
youtube
i feel like being on youtube is not a
thing i really do at all
if you mean watching youtube that is i
don't watch any youtube content
creating youtube content um obviously
i'm doing that right now but
the truth is the time management of it
is that i'm doing something else at the
same time
uh it's not difficult because you know
my youtube channel is a hobby and not a
job
so there i just do it when i have free
time that's why i always upload late
though like i'll upload at 11 pm or
midnight or something
um because i am very frequently uh doing
it at the end of a workday
so we finish at funhouse at six so
that's why my uploads are always very
late but um there isn't really a time
management issue with
making youtube content or streaming uh
do i plan to have play watch listen go
back monthly once the world is back to
normal it's honestly the highlight of my
week thank you
the highlight of my week too i love that
show
um look it's not we don't plan to have
it go back
monthly and i think we would all really
miss it if that happened and we have
spoken about this in episodes before
it just may have to happen um because
people have to fly to events
especially troy i feel like he's all
over the world all the time sometimes it
just may not be possible for us to
make the show that we are currently
making when
when everyone schedules back to normal
um
so it just might be a reality it's not a
plan it's not something we even want to
do it just may have to happen
um but no matter what i don't want to
stop
the show so we'll do it the way we can
pretty much no matter what we will make
it
as consistently as we can however
possible
is the idea
why not youtube full-time i have no
desire to ever do that
i've said it before a number of times
but um
i have zero interest in working solo
my my whole driving thing as a human
is to learn that's literally
like it's it's just ravenclaw as [ __ ]
i want to learn and be smarter and be
better
and help people as much as possible so
running a youtube channel by myself i
feel like that's not me working with
people who i can learn from that's me
working by myself
um not that people on youtube aren't
smart i cannot say that
but i think the only way that you grow
as a human is if you
at least for me uh i work with people
that i can learn from and grow with and
yeah i just always want to know more
[ __ ] and know how to do more [ __ ]
um and that just doesn't exist for me on
youtube i like working with teams and i
like
yeah working with people who have a lot
more experience than me
d flowers recently got diagnosed with
cfs anything that has helped with you
i wish dude the answer is no uh it shows
up whenever it wants to
and [ __ ] sucks is the truth i have
literally no tips
um my biggest one and i think the most
important thing about it and something
that i still have to try to do all the
time
is don't hate yourself uh because it can
be
cfs sucks and no matter what you'll have
people tell you it's not real because
you don't visibly look ill i look tired
all the time people tell me that all the
time like why is she look so tired why
is she so low energy i'm like well
because i have an illness but
that doesn't quite pass as looking sick
enough or disabled enough
um so like you can feel this constant
like guilt of like
i'm not sick enough why can't i function
uh so the most important thing for me
because like i've had it for a really
long time i just only officially told
people i had it at the start of last
year
um otherwise i was preferred to like
keep it very quiet frankly
but i hadn't uploaded any youtube videos
in like four months and my appearances
in funhouse were wavering so i felt like
i kind of had to say
hey had to say something um so yeah you
can hate yourself a lot and i think the
the biggest thing is just like don't do
that
just try to remember that it's not your
fault as frustrating as it is
that you are dealing with that thing um
because i had this mantra when it when
it was first kicking my butt when i was
like maybe
i think maybe 17 i don't remember to be
completely honest um
where i would like tell myself i hated
myself all the time be like [ __ ] hate
myself i hate i'm a piece of [ __ ] why am
i doing this
and i had to like really train that out
and it's it is an ongoing process but
that's the thing that i think can hurt
you the most
otherwise jaden any tips for getting
into games journalism
also what parts of cyberpunk have you
the most hyped
there are two videos on my youtube
channel that i would recommend you check
out or if you just want to go to my
instagram they're on like the highlights
thing it's how i got my job
um i would suggest you check those out
because those are the most helpful
ah my chat's disappearing it's literally
out loaded itself i'm sorry so i've
missed the other questions that were in
there
um but yes i have a bunch of resources
already on youtube about literally
exactly everything i did to get into
games of journalism so i would check
those out
it's the highlight that says how i got
my job on instagram check that one out
has tons of tons of info
i'm not killing the chat it's not my
fault i'm not doing it on purpose it's
just happening in front of me
ah thank you verb have i don't know how
to pronounce your name i'm so sorry
yeah i've been doing a lot of manga
streams it's uh that game especially has
helped
i think i've gotten too good at it it's
the biggest problem
and now people are trying to kill me
first because i'm too good at being
detective
not that good at being an imposter
that's like 50 50.
uh but it is a really good game
for me because it feels like a social
outlet so
[Music]
thank you stefan thank you riot and
respect i appreciate that
jray i spoke about horror films and
stuff on the most recent episode of play
watch listen
you are on youtube it is on youtube um
it's hereditary i love that movie
oh thank you i appreciate that tyler
yeah invisible illnesses uh
suck is the truth um
[Music]
it's a [ __ ] that's all i really have to
say
it's my go-to meal when i want to feel
better it's mac and cheese
a basic [ __ ]
i love it though do you drive in america
i can
any youtube creators i feel deserve more
love
i don't watch youtube sadly so i don't
know how to speak about that
i don't know
would you rather work for free or be
underpaid
uh
depends what it is like there's
something that i'm working on right now
that i really hope i can announce soon
um i'm very excited about
that is completely for free but you know
i'm
technically sure running the thing it's
my choice to do that and i would not
want to be paid for it if i was offered
money for it i would be like yeah now
i'm uncomfortable with that
is this a new camera no this is uh
logitech brio the lighting's just better
it's at the mypetal library
very nice uh what time is it here it is
10 30. i still have a lot of [ __ ]
work to do
do i have eyelash extensions emily i do
not right now
but when i do i love those i love them
i miss them thank you jihad
do i enjoy traveling absolutely i think
that's like in australian's blood
if i'm completely honest it's like
kind of a thing um that we all just
travel a lot
um i don't know why that's happened uh
i was talking to someone about that
really recently um
yeah we're all over the world pretty
much so
um dex guy yeah i have not published any
of my writing but i've been writing for
a very long time
i don't care about people reading it i
don't know why
um i've had friends read things that
i've written obviously
and they all tend to like it i just
don't care about
the rest of the world reading it and i
don't know why i don't care
um i would maybe publish something if it
were for charity but generally like i
feel like i write because i enjoy
writing
rather than writing because i want
people to read it
so maybe it's because so much of my life
is already very online
and and so much of my job has been so
public all the time
that having the uh
having something that i have that i've
always been very passionate about being
fiction writing obviously even my
journal of
journalism has always been public
obviously i did a lot of writing and
editing a lot of [ __ ] editing for
inside gaming
um that having some of my writing just
not be shared with the world is
comforting
um
yeah i might do it eventually i'm not
sure
[Laughter]
somebody asked not to be political but
what are your political views in great
detail
that's pretty political bro
oh thank you jet there's aud
good i might has account
uh my game attack is charlotte's odd it
should be the same as my
url do i like working with inside gaming
dude i love working with literally
[ __ ] everyone at inside gaming
that team is amazing all of them dear
god
fantastic people just so good
um okay i need to keep doing this before
this
[ __ ] macbook dies because it is going
to die
yes
this was not that day this is gonna be
12 30 to 1 30. there we go
12 30 pm to
1 30 pm
thank you dan i appreciate that
would i accept invitations to talk in
other podcasts depends on the podcast of
course i have
but it depends on what they are am i
going to upload more on this channel
after leaving funhouse
[ __ ] i'm already uploading like twice a
day you want more
son what um
but to be fully clear i've only been
uploading so much
because of lockdown um because of
quarantine so
i'm just trying to fill all of my spare
time where i'm just locked in an
apartment by myself with
stuff i'm making so i only started
uploading as much as i have in june
um otherwise it was always like once or
twice a week and
in theory hopefully when lockdown ends i
will go back to
once or twice a week um like i said this
has only happened because i'm trying to
fill all my spare time with productivity
so that i don't go [ __ ] insane
uh but this isn't a standard that i
intend to set for a long time by any
means
it's just now it's also just leading up
to next generation consoles i've just
been trying to make the stuff that
people have been asking me to make
just been trying to be helpful um
because i have access to the things and
if people have questions about the
things i can give them answers to the
things about the things
you know what i'm saying
okay speed test thank you jacob
who's the best spelling member of kind
of funny i have no idea i mean about
joey
guess play watch listen we've spoken
about that a lot too i don't think
uh that we should do that um
it would ruin the chemistry and that
show is all about chemistry it's not
not just about what our job roles are
it's about who we are as
um and how we get along and how we
listen to each other and
yeah so i i think that guests would just
make it feel like a completely different
show so
i presently have no plans to but we're
not against it
if it makes sense at some point when we
were going to do our spoiler cast we
were going to have neil druckmann on
but uh then mike never finished the game
so you could take that up with mike
bithell all right
it's mike's fault okay that's all i'm
saying
7 30 0 8
10 20.
this is quite painful i'm doing my
invoices for
inside gaming for the week that the atom
stuff went down
um which because i'm a contractor
and because of the way it went down they
gave like fun house and everyone
time off but i didn't get any they all
get paid for that
but i don't so
this is like brutal to look at uh you
know even though i'm on phone calls with
them and chatting with them but all that
[ __ ]
and like organizing that same [ __ ]
everyone else was they all get paid and
i don't
oh it's so sad like wow
yup i made no money that week cool
thanks adam appreciate it it's like
literally nothing
so that's fun
i did go to university mr chris prunk i
studied journalism and entertainment
it's actually a bachelor of mass
communication but uh
it does suck it does suck
like
i feel like i should i don't know that i
didn't even talk about this publicly but
i'm like the
little amount of money that i made that
week like
doesn't cover my rent for that week
i'm not salaried so
how did i pay for my education great
question snoopy rice
don't have to shout out to australia
punched my microphone
yikes
don't have to pay [ __ ] it's great
okay do i think the series x is better
engineered than the ps5 stefan
ask an engineer that question
ah
i'm not an expert on that [ __ ] i've
never been an expert on hardware
i would consider myself an expert on
video games
i know how they are developed i know how
they are made and i've played
a [ __ ] lot of them don't care what
platform they're on
um okay so that's gonna be
this week oh it's bad oh it's not good
it's real sad actually
you know what's [ __ ] up being
completely candid
because of like the time it took for
them to let adam go
adam made more money in this week than i
did
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh god it's so sad
all right well you know thanks for the
hundred dollars
he would have made so much more and i
would have been like going negative on
my groceries
[Laughter]
jeez okay
hey we're on to the next week we started
again on tuesday
so it gets a little bit better from
there
but there is technically two weeks of us
like easing into content where i just
got
[ __ ] it's so brutal
oh thank you chris i appreciate it
there are no ndas regarding adam no
or anything i think people think things
are ndate a lot more than they are
but they are not yeah it's a green
screen this is not a real bookshelf i
[ __ ] wish though that is like one of
my life goals is that one day i could
have a bookshelf that looks this cool
i would love that
just i've been to bernie's house before
bernie burns
i don't remember what color it was but
he has a bookshelf that is a wall
that they intentionally just bought
either it's either yellow or blue and i
don't remember which color all the books
in it are just yellow or blue and it
looks so [ __ ] cool
it's beautiful um that would be just
just the dream i can't make that happen
thank you anna alchemist and john news i
appreciate that
i have watched lawn mower man yes
uh now i do not have any interest in
being an affiliate slash partner on
twitch
i might do it eventually again not a
thing i'm necessarily against
but uh i don't want it to ever feel like
a job and i don't want
people to feel like i owe them streams
um
when i'm not a content creator it's my
job
so you know
xbox fridge is cool you keep asking like
it's cool i don't know what else you
have to say
i'm planning on doing voice acting in
the future again of course
[Music]
thank you sid aunt
i absolutely think you can move into the
games industry at age 27. 100
you can yeah
there's a definitely no issues there at
all
absolutely a thing
what would i say is the biggest lesson i
learned while working for ign
um the first thing that came to my head
was
don't let other people take credit for
your work um but i
largely had a very positive experience
working for agn um
there was just one person who kept
taking credit for my work and i let them
do it because i was like well everyone
works we're all a team and then it kind
of [ __ ] me
um
[Music]
i don't know i don't i don't know what
my answer to that would be
i i really enjoyed working there and a
lot of my best friends still work there
i had a really good time
um it was really hard
but i like pod
but yeah i don't know if they have
anything other than that to really say
have i played watch dogs legions uh
oh well yes i did play it because i
streamed it um
but i have barely paid any attention to
it sadly because
most of the time i've played it i've
streamed it so i've not even really
absorbed it i might try and play some
more this week
best game i've played this year
it'll be goes to sushima now that the
multiplayer is out it'll be your sushima
do i miss working in ign or only are
friends there
um
i miss getting to visit studios fun
house was very against that
um inside gaming as well like i loved
getting to go to game studios and i just
for some reason like i thought that we
would be allowed to do that
at funhouse but they were like it's a
waste of time no so
i miss that for sure um i
absolutely miss the people i work with
but
like i don't regret leaving or anything
like that
any marriage plans no
what's your biggest personal epiphany
damn y'all getting [ __ ] deep out here
my biggest personal epiphany i think
um this is obviously very specific to my
position but probably helps
it probably applies to more people than
just me uh
you are not responsible for what other
people think of you
um there will be two thousand versions
of you
for me maybe it's a million two thousand
versions of of you that live in other
people's heads
and it is not your job to change them
and it is also impossible to change them
i've always said that one of the
weirdest things about being a public
figure
is watching people confidently lie about
you and watching other people believe it
so like
people will just straight up make up
[ __ ] sometimes i think they believe what
they're saying which is the weirdest
part uh there was something like the
other week that i was like i never said
that but these people are all agreeing
that i did and i've never said this
thing
and i think they just like invent [ __ ]
even accidentally sometimes
um but you can't correct any of it
because it would be a waste of time
because there's too much of it
which is very weird it's just a weird
thing to be like
you're lying for whatever reason all
these other people are believing you and
that's an even weirder part why the [ __ ]
you believing a stranger on the internet
why are you not even gonna fact check
what's wrong with you but they don't
um but you just have to be like it's not
not my responsibility what you think of
me i have to just
have fun whatever i i gotta keep being
me and keep making stuff i like and keep
trying to
do good things and you can think
whatever the [ __ ] you want
um i think that's the thing that yeah i
learned as i hit maybe like 25 that uh
has helped
favorite twitch stream aside from
yourself my favorite twitch stream life
and being completely honest is andy
cortez
um i generally only watch my friends
stream but
it would be andy cortez yeah i really
love jumping into his dreams i think
that the way that he um
gives his chat [ __ ] is very funny
uh
yeah i love andy i find him super
entertaining
yeah his chat's really mean to him but
it's because he's mean back i just
yeah i love andy a lot have i met morgan
webb
i have not the nitro rifle indeed
oh yeah i really like uh ray as well um
i mean i like all my friends who would
stream this frankly uh but
yeah andy i think
i've probably watched more of him than
almost anyone else and i love insulting
him in chat
it's a good time have i met felicia day
i have a number of times
someone who hasn't had much experience
with fps you might recommend cyberpunk
as a possible place to start
cyberpunk is an rpg
start with titanfall 2. that's your
first fps little baby go play titanfall
2.
highly recommend
clarissa do people ever recognize you on
the street
son i don't go out on the street
i ain't been outdoors in days
do i still talk with jessie cox yeah
jessie and i are friends
of course okay
[Music]
ryan yeah i'm planning to go back to
australia next year hopefully again i
don't know
i'm guessing it's a public persona you
constantly come across bizarre off-base
stuff about yourself
i mean constantly but again the weirdest
[ __ ] is people saying that i said things
that i didn't i became a source for
saying that the halo infinite build was
six months old i never said that there's
no video of me saying that
and sometimes someone would be like
where did she say that and then they
would link to a video
where i didn't say that like people just
like crediting me with something
i never said it's very strange but i've
also had like more
like elaborate [ __ ] like people be like
yeah i had a one night stand with her
and everyone replies and is like oh what
was it like give me the details
as a person who has literally never had
a one night stand in my entire life and
never would
because dude don't want anything to do
with strangers um
it's bizarre that people are like yes i
believe you what
why no it's so stupid anyone could walk
in and say that
doesn't make any sense
what game am i playing right now on my
xbox series x
i've given my xbox series x to conor
mcgraw
for uh inside gaming content so i don't
have it right now
conor has it
supernatural experiences we spoke about
the only supernatural experience i've
ever had on the most recent fun house
um uh dude soup episode lady broth we
called it
my macbook died on page three of
invoices
so i probably should roll i said i
wasn't going to do this for too long
and i think it's been an hour
right surely it doesn't make two hours
that can't be right
surely surely 58 minutes that's what i
thought
uh series x or ps5 nothing to do with
the console wars just your personal
experiences
personal preference sorry here's my
personal preference i
don't give a flying [ __ ]
that's i don't [ __ ] care
never have um i literally don't have a
preference just give me video games
and if you want me to like try it again
into a preference
which of course again people will take
this out of proportion and i'll get
called sony she'll
uh i am more excited for a lot of
upcoming playstation exclusives than i
am for
xbox exclusives um not that i
necessarily
support the exclusive landscape but the
number one game i'm excited about is
death loop which is
uh a there's the title so it'll probably
come to xbox eventually
um and miles morales and ration clank
are my top three
and those are all playstation exclusives
but uh otherwise
i don't [ __ ] care
it's the truth i don't care at all
uh thank you tyler my leg yeah so i
broke my kneecap
not great um it is doing better actually
this week i think
so it's been like it's been three weeks
or two weeks
since i broke it and um still hurts
whenever i walk standing up is really
bad
but uh if i just have it straight now it
doesn't hurt all the time which i think
means that
the swelling has disappeared so
i'm happy about that
how did that happen uh i fainted and
smashed it into bathroom tiles
well thank you the wacky world
impossible i appreciate that
[Music]
i don't use a cane i do not
no i didn't have to get surgery
my photo band died yeah i did it out of
solidarity
uh thank you freddie i appreciate that
also keeps talking about random people i
closely know the last few episodes
that's weird that is trippy
you're right that would be [ __ ] weird
um i don't have any opinions i can share
on ac valhalla
is that covered by work health insurance
since you're working from home [ __ ] i
don't have
health insurance through work
devastatingly
i pay for my own it sucks
um you add anything else to your batman
collection i do have
one box that got sent to the fun house
office that's too big for me to fit
in a car that i
was the thing that i even forgot i
ordered so
i have to figure out i've like had
conversations at omar about it and i'm
like can i just wait until clovid is
over to get like a truck to pick this up
because i don't know how to do this
otherwise
it's really large my god
why did you faint in the bathroom i mean
not by choice it wasn't
like i saw something unfainted i can't
vote stop asking me if i can vote
i'm foreign do i clean my figurines i
dust them yes
i like to dust them uh why am i fainting
um that's just part of cfs
how did i come to support liverpool
there is uh
no interesting answer to this
um
how do i suck at making good contracts
with my employers get a lawyer
that's really [ __ ] dumb you're an
idiot um
a lot of australians are liveable fans
somehow um
three of my family members though my dad
is a tottenham supporter
which is fun actually we have good
banter um but yeah
liverpool are just very popular in
australia and i think it's because we've
had aussies who played for
lfc so just kind of happened how do i
feel my health has been this year
compared to last year thank you for
asking
um way better because i can chill when i
need to
so it's very nice it's really nice
doing i've been doing a lot better
i think when does the embargo for new
consoles lift
for xbox it's gonna be wednesday
the playstation embargoes is staggered
so different times
all right i have more work that i need
to do that requires being filmed so i
need to go
and film this
um thanks for hanging out you guys this
this literally what i was doing at
voices but this is dead though
so it died and there is no nearby
powerpoint for me to plug anything into
so the thing that i was doing
we have run out of time for thank you
all for joining them this is the first
time i've ever done one of these so
did i do it right like i don't know if
this is how these are supposed to go
like am i supposed to bring topics i
don't know
[Laughter]
hopefully i did it okay
thank you uh
all right i will see you guys next time